this episode was made possible by
generous supporters on patreon Pepe
Paideia crazies well at least if you
live in one of these countries anyway I
was thinking recently does the number pi
actually exist let's find out of course
if we really can't answer this without a
pinch of definition the number pi is
defined as the ratio of a circles
circumference to its diameter yes there
are a bunch of different ways to
calculate it but as three blue one Brown
would remind us all of them are somehow
related to circles so if we're going to
ask if the number pi exists it might be
helpful to first ask if a circle exists
a circle is the set of all points
equidistant from the same point but
that's just math it's abstract stuff
can we actually draw a shape with that
property well let's give it a shot
find a piece of paper and a compass the
ends of the compass have a consistent
distance so it should be perfect I can
put it on my paper twirl it around and
bam I've got a circle or do I let us
take a closer look at that you can
quickly see places where I was a bit
wobbly with the compass sometimes it's
so bad my curve doesn't even reconnect
with itself but even if I didn't suck at
drawing I'm still limited by the width
of the line the graphite material in the
pencil and imperfections in the paper so
let's try something manufactured a
little better like this pant if I
measure the diameter all the way around
it seems consistent at least to the
precision of my measuring device which
brings us to our first problem with
physical objects if you measure the
circumference in the diameter and then
divide those two numbers you'll get
something close to pi but not exactly pi
you can't know for sure that it's a
perfect circle but what if it is a
perfect circle then despite exist and
not so fast
this brings us to our second problem
with physical objects even if this pan
is as round as physically possible it's
still not a perfect circle superzoom if
you get close enough you can see atoms
there are sides to this shape they're
just really tiny ones and curved ones at
that
also we're now assumed in so much that
size and shapes start to lose meaning
even the digital circle I showed you
earlier is made of pixels on your screen
if you put your eyeball right up against
the screen you see something like this
that's not a smooth edge so I don't know
if this whole circle thing is gonna pan
out anyway all this talk about circles
reminds me of this experiment that
physics girl did a while back she and
veritasium threw a bunch of darts at a
board with circles drawn on it
the ratio of darts that landed inside
the circles compared to the total should
be proportional to pi roughly you know
what I'm kind of in the mood to check
the limits of that experiment computer
simulation time here is a board hit with
a thousand darts ten thousand darts a
hundred thousand and a million I ran
each simulation a hundred times and
there's a definite decrease in the
average error the more darts you have
unfortunately sometimes randomness comes
in lumps if I ran the simulation enough
times there would eventually be one
where all the darts landed inside the
circle and I'd get a little over 27
percent error the point is there will
always be some error with this
experiment
that being said Diana and Derek got
really great results you should go check
it out hold up I think I hear comments
incoming all computers do is work with
numbers so your simulation is assuming
PI exists in order to prove Pi exists
check mate
let's make a few things clear one I
haven't come to any conclusions so you
shouldn't either - oh you want to play
the pedantic game you're going up
against the master technically speaking
computers don't work with numbers in a
computer there are a bunch of
transistors controlling the flow of
electricity the electricity is either
flowing or it isn't that's the reality
we simply interpret a flow as a one and
a lack of flow as a zero because it
allows us to interpret complex flows of
electricity as binary math there's no
actual numbers there it's just
electricity but you know what let's
pretend they are numbers for a minute
even if we do that pi is not one of
those numbers
a typical processor these days is 64-bit
which means each register is 64 bits
long each bit can either be a 0 or a 1
so we're working with binary math
unfortunately that doesn't mean we get
up to 64 binary digits we'd like to work
with negative numbers as well as
positive ones also like most numbers pi
has decimal places remember it looks
like this in decimal form there's a
decimal point in binary it looks like
this there's still a point but this is
binary so we call it a binary point
instead a computer needs the handle
numbers like this so we let the point
float around the 64-bit register that's
why it's called a floating point number
okay so we sacrifice one bit for the
sign then eleven more bits for an
exponent the actual digits of the number
only get the remaining 52 bits in binary
scientific notation a number looks like
this so the best the computer can do
with pi is this converting that only
gets us 18 decimal places what if it's
like a super mega advanced processor
there will still be a limit they do make
highly-specialized 256 bit processors
which means more digits but there will
always be a finite number of them the
number pi has an infinite number of
digits computers can only ever store an
approximation of pi naught pi itself we
don't kale it an irrational number for
nothing I mean there is no discernable
pattern whatsoever in those digits it's
crazy right actually this might be a
better way to handle our original
question does the number pi actually
exist let's imagine that all numbers are
on this hypothetical line it's got all
the natural numbers 1 2 3 4 5 etc zero
is on there too as well as all the
negative integers it's also pretty easy
to imagine rational numbers you just
make ratios of the integers 1/2 negative
33 over 4 10 thirds negative 1/12 each
with a corresponding decimal version
that either ends or repeats irrational
numbers are a bit s'more difficult mole
ratios just gives you more rational
numbers but let's say you've got a
triangle with two equal sides
we'll give them a length of one that's
no big deal one is an integer what we're
pretty comfortable with that
unfortunately the length of the
remaining side is root 2
- is irrational you can't write it as a
ratio of integers it's decimal places go
on forever with no pattern there are
lots of root examples but pi is even
weirder
it's transcendental meaning it isn't the
solution to any algebraic equation with
rational coefficients it transcends
algebra but numbers like root two and pi
have to be on the number line if it's
going to be continuous
without them there would be gaps for
that reason we call this line the real
number line because it contains all real
numbers so the real question here is
this do space and time work like the
number line is space time continuous
well general relativity would have you
think so it models space as being like
the real number line in all three
dimensions and also models time the same
way but this fact about general
relativity is what makes it
fundamentally inconsistent with quantum
mechanics for gravity to work like the
other interactions and quantum mechanics
space and time must be discrete they
must come in little pieces that's the
exact opposite of continuous in a model
like that having gaps in the number line
would be perfectly acceptable it might
be that no irrational numbers exists let
alone pi unfortunately we don't have a
model like this yet at least one that
works until then we won't have a
definite answer so what do you think our
space and time continuous or discrete
this pie exists Duke it out in the
comments thanks for liking and sharing
this video a special thanks goes out to
patreon patrons like Albert B cannon and
Tim ruffles who helped keep the show
going with their incredible generosity
thank you so much do not forget to
subscribe if you'd like to keep up with
us and until next time remember it's
okay to be a little crazy genefex was
wondering what are blackhole spinning
relative to right motion is relative so
you have to assign the coordinates to
someone in the case of black holes
that's usually a distant inertial
observer it's not always explicitly
stated but it is the standard anyway
thanks for watching